a mystery solved a priceless item stolen
years ago is back with its rightful
owner it is thanks to Clues left
behind she confided to me that she had a
scrapbook that her um biological mom had
left her
St
I never did this fight did should be
okay we had purchased this photo frame
used out of Goodwill back in Iowa where
we lived and I found this little bitty
memory card we started clicking the
picture
and we've seen all these memories we
took 2 or 3 hours at Christmas day
trying to find Clues I found out it was
from a town called lyette
Alabama to hear them again brought back
by Joy especially how she love the kids
look at now there are still miracles in
this
world
PE